- Morgen zusammen.
- Morgen.
- Guten Morgen.
- Sprechen wir mal den heutigen Tag durch,
… damit ihr starten könnt. Also wir fangen
jetzt heute Morgen an bei der Familie Jäger
mit einer Wartung,
eine Ölheizungsanlage, ja?
Einschließlich Warmwasserspeicher, ne?
- Kein Problem!
- Ja, wir überprüfen die
Gasleistung … das Übliche.
Da hab ich einen Termin vereinbart
zwischen 8 und 9 Uhr.
Ja, als nächstes, zwischen 10 und
11 Uhr haben wir ein Füllventil
bei der Familie Schürmann – Füllventil
am Spülkasten zu tauschen.
Und der Rest vom Tag ist
dann wahrscheinlich
auch ein sehr anstrengendes Programm,
könnte auch eine Stunde länger werden,
bei der Baustelle im Himbeergarten
22 in dem Badezimmer
bei der Badsanierung die Fußbodenheizung
muss noch fertig verlegt werden.
Und die muss heute aber komplett rein,
weil morgen schon der Estrich gelegt wird.
Okay, hat der Estrichleger was
mit der Unterdämmung zu tun
oder machen wir das?
- Das machen wir alles komplett.
- Alles klar, gut!
Ja, wir brauchen einmal unser Füllventil.
- Ja. Hab ich.
- Dann brauchen wir unseren
Dichtungssatz für die Wartung.
- Ja okay.
- Und als Nächstes brauchen
wir noch unsere Verschraubung
für die Fußbodenheizung.
So, dann haben wir unser Material,
jetzt brauchen wir noch unsere Geräte.
- Genau. Weißt du denn,
was wir alles brauchen?
- Du nimmst bitte einmal die
Pressmaschine mit und …
- Und die Überziehschuhe, ne?
- Und die Überziehschuhe.
Und jetzt haben wir noch den Messkoffer,
den packe ich noch mit ein.
Warte, ich mach dir die Tür auf.